la petite fille qui me permet de rester
actif on va courir à tout les jours
jamais dans sa remorque on se promène on
va dans les parcs tout daniel pépin
dirige un club de karaté très présent
dans les écoles de la rive-sud l'été des
centaines de jeunes s'inscrivent à 50
jours l'entraîneur pense que ces
activités pourraient recommencer à la
fin juin
j'imagine qu'une façon de le faire pour
les camps d'été où c'est gore à
l'extérieur avec des espaces plus que ce
soit éducatif pour les jeunes agréable
en même temps mais éducatif long combat
dans les arts martiaux les adversaires
mais là ça pète combattre cette jardin
grippe pour eux et que ce soit je pense
naturellement si les écoles vont être
ouverts pour les jeunes la suite logique
c'est que les camps d'été aussi vont
devoir être disponible à brossard la
ville espère pouvoir offrir des comptes
jours mais il accueillerait deux fois
moins d'enfants en raison de la
distanciation sociale et les moniteurs
recevront une formation sur la
prévention
on vaut les encourager à faire des
activités où il n'y a pas de contacts
humains
j'avais demandé d exemple aux abeilles
on peut jouer le jeu où est-ce qu'on
restait comme statut semblait y voit des
activités des choses créatif et novateur
[Musique]
en gaspésie les inquiétudes sont
partagées
d'un côté on craint que si la région est
rouverte les cas de co vide augmente de
l'autre on a peur que les touristes
restent chez eux cet été
c'est une cas de cet hôtel hier il s'est
employé du spot sans peau et qui est pas
du tout mais il n'y a pas cette année
clos
c'est comme à yellowstone et la chine ou
la géode de faire quelque chose on
endort commence à bord du monde
l'entrepreneur de carleton sur mer pense
pouvoir offrir ces forfaits de
thalassothérapie de façon sécuritaire
avec d'eisai loges réinstalle melocco ge
on va envelopper oui mais différemment
pour justement créé cette distanciation
l'eau tout en ayant comme le côté
confortable khune on a une très grande
piscine d'eau de mer en mettant un
circuit d'entrée et de sortie puis de
limiter le nombre de personnes dans les
bassins d'eau les sentiers et les
campings des parcs nationaux et fédéraux
comme les chic chocs et le parc forillon
vont rester fermés probablement jusqu'en
juin seront telle ouvert cet été
on ne sait pas encore on continuer à
évaluer la situation on commente parce
qu'on vous annonce aujourd'hui on fait
bien des scénarios comme je disais hier
on en fait pendant des fêtes tout les
jours à peu près 5 6 10 11 et angoisse
celui là ça va être le bon pile la main
et monsieur legault dit quelque chose
non ça sera aux poteaux
quand on va repartir de voir des
nouvelles cités faut pas penser à
repartir comme en ces temps de se
réinventer et si sophie langlois radio
canada montréal